on voit bien avec ces trois exemples
concrets que nous en france on se met
une systématiquement une balle dans le
pied pour la compétitivité de nos
agriculteurs
très rapidement je laisse le mot de la
fin à yannick fialip pour cette table
ronde
et puis on enchaîne avec les deux thèmes
thème suivant merci peter alors c'est
vrai que on s'appelle on se connaît très
bien
alors ça va peter hill et vernon colas
et c'est jean pierre et on s'appelle
voilà mes cheveux se laisse un comble
non je voulais revenir sur toi être
félicitée pour l'intervention que tu as
fait hier à l'assemblée nationale a
interpellé le premier ministre
et c'est monsieur fall qui t'a répondu
et j'ai vu la réponse qui m'a fait froid
dans le dos monsieur le fola dit mais on
a fait beaucoup dans cette majorité pour
l'agriculture notamment à travers le
plan de compétitivité on a mis un
milliard huit pour les agriculteurs
alors là je dis mais c'est où ils sont
passés parce que non les a pas vus et au
contraire je vais vous dire avec deux
mesures qui se sont concrètement mis en
place sur des exploitations de ma région
1 en 2012 monsieur hollande a supprimé
la dpi sur les investissements c'est à
dire qu'on pouvait mettre un peu
d'argent de côté quand on privée
d'investissement il l'a supprimée ça
s'est traduit pour les exploitations
moyennes montagnes comme les miennes en
haute loire par 4 à 5000 euros de
cotisations sociales ou d'impôts en plus
voilà donc c'est ça et le le concret
deuxième chose il a décidé de supprimer
les heures supplémentaires je sais que
vous faire plaisir mais c'est un sujet
de compétitivité en france
il se trouve que le lait qu'on produit
on en produit le plus à certains mois
c'est au mois de mai passe toutes les
vaches français sont à l'air toujours là
bon et donc on en produit beaucoup cela
il se trouve le mois de mai selon moi où
il ya le plus de jours fériés et en 2015
il n'y a pas eu une semaine complète
qu'est ce qu'on fait les vaches dans
produits les nos producteurs non on a
ramassé les on l'a très en laminant
camion le camion est arrivé à la
laiterie mais malheureusement la
laiterie il y avait la moitié des
personnels qui travaillent est parce qu
à moitié avait pris ses jours de congés
et rtt
n'ayant plus d'heures supplémentaires
ils n'ont pas voulu travailler s'il
n'est pas la carotte seul et là il va
falloir faire quelque chose on
l'envoyait nos voisins européens qui
chaque année le connaissent maintenant
ils nous disent on demande mais vous
avez envoyé des tonnes de lait donc on
vous attend donc on n'achète pas cher on
le transforme dans nos usines et trois
mois après on renvoie en france 1
conques raconte un cas concret qui pèse
sur la compétitivité 2 de la filière et
donc de mon exploitation et qui fait
baisser peut-être le prix du lait de 10
euros la tonne chose
voilà merci à toi mais
si sincèrement d'intervenants pour vos
explications très concret